it's great it's nice because every day
is an adventure well the adventure is
about to get
even more wild because bindi irwin
is having a baby i'm excited i'm really
excited
the 22 year old australian wildlife
activist and her hubby chandler powell
hit up instagram tuesday to share the
news that she's pregnant
with their first child you're kind of
like my soul mate
bindi shared this sweet shot alongside
the caption
baby wildlife warrior dude 2021
adding chandler and i are proud to
announce that we're expecting
it's an honor to share this special
moment in our lives with you
but you guys that teeny tiny
khaki shirt i can't i love seeing you in
cocky now it makes me so happy
anywho the daughter of the late steve
irwin went on to reveal that she's still
in her first trimester
but she really wants her fans to be a
part of their journey from the jump
quote
we couldn't wait to share the news as
this beautiful little being has become
the most
important part of our lives as for
chandler
he's over the moon about their incoming
bundle of joy
the 23 year old shared the same pic to
his insta
writing becoming a dad is the highlight
of my life
i cannot wait to embark on this new
adventure and life chapter with my
gorgeous wife
now cue the oz because
then he said this b you're going to be
the most
amazing mother i'm really grateful to
have found you
i don't think i could be with anyone
else in the world to be honest
bindi and chandler tied the knot back in
march in australia
after getting engaged last july having
the
wedding here at australia zoo that's
that's what means the most and with my
family it'll be really special
back in 2018 bindi told et that she felt
like her late dad would have given
chandler a former pro wakeboarder from
florida
his stamp of approval what do you think
dad would have thought of that great guy
oh
i i hope he'd like jayla i think he
would i mean taylor
is wonderful he's always up for the
challenge so i hope dad would love
chandler and
you know we all love him i think he's
great i think i think your dad would
have
tested him morning noon and night
and then approved because your dad was
kind of like that radon always used to
say if you're going to date a guy he has
to cross the crock pond fast like swim
across the croc pond
and thankfully chandler was a
wakeboarder so you know what
wakeboarding across the crock pond i'm
sure he would have passed the test
shortly after tying the knot et spoke
with bindi about keeping her last name
irwin as a tribute to her dad i think
that
for me personally you know after after
dad passed away it was
really important for you to feel close
to him and having his last name
so much to me but i think that um for us
sharing car keys is just as much
i don't like taking each other's last
night has become an airline
yeah totally which is awesome but i
think that yeah we'll
we'll both always have our [ __ ] jeans on
yeah
you're in irwin through and through we
talked about it a lot and
you're in another one yeah it's it's a
bit of
but i think i think it's it's really
special though everyone has their own
unique ideas
the nice thing is that it's 20 20 now so
anything works
as for chandler he credits the late
crocodile hunter star for bringing them
together as a couple
the biggest thing i would like to say to
him is just thank you
for inspiring my passion in life and
also
bringing me and ben together because if
it weren't for him i don't know how he
would have met